ce juge gascon mon cher que les mains je
vous donne le mot de la fin
lundi dernier la semaine dernière
j'avais dit au juge en chef que je
voulais que le moment soit discret que
j'étais peu friand d'être le centre de
l'attention
disons que je réalise que bien malgré
moi j'ai fais tout en mon possible pour
que ce soit précisément le contraire
aujourd'hui c'est ma dernière journée
d'audience
je l' ai vécu avec un plaisir bien senti
mon travail de juge est loin d'être
complété je peux vous assurer que je
veux continuer un ensemble
alan savourer pleinement chacun des
instants un gros merci à tous du fond du
coeur
[Applaudissements]